Gentlemen, congratulations.
You are both moving forward
into the third and final round
of this competition.
Now, in this last
round we're going
to ask you to go back
to your home forges
and build an iconic
weapon from history that
has been shrouded in mystery.
Gentlemen, we want
you to build this--
the Medieval Sword of Mystery.
The Medieval Sword of Mystery
has been puzzling historians
for centuries.
This double-edged broadsword
features a double fuller,
making it light enough to
wield single-handed, delivering
fast, lethal strikes.
The sword was found in the River
Witham in East England in 1825.
It's believed to
have been forged
back in the 13th century,
although its exact origin
is a mystery.
Even more mysterious,
the blade has
a gold inlaid inscription
etched into the steel
in an unknown language.
Several years ago, the
British Museum recruited
the public to help decipher it.
But to this day, no one has
been able to crack the code.
Bladesmiths, you
will have four days
to build your medieval
swords of mystery.
So, good luck.
See you guys in four days.
Good luck.
Good luck, buddy.
LARRY: My name is Larry
Rhodes, 44 years old.
I live in Fulton, Kansas.
I'm kind of a perfectionist,
kind of from the old school.
If you're going to do it, do
it right or don't do it at all.
I think what I need
to do to win is
I need to hit the wow factor.
That's ready to go in the forge.
I'm going to run two
billets at the same time
so I'm not waiting on it.
All right, here we
go, billet number two.
Got good welds on it, and
I'm thinking it will be OK.
I'm going to grab
the two billets,
put a right-hand twist in
one, and a left-hand twist
in the other, cut them
up and restack them.
Well, here we go.
Well, it looks like I have
a piece with a crack in it.
It starts here, goes
down, over, and back up.
I'm going to go ahead and go
to plan B. I got a bar of 5160,
so I'm just going to go
ahead and put it in the forge
and run it on out.
Looking forward
for the wow factor.
It's not going to happen.
All right, here we go.
Perfect.
Right now we're back on track.
Yeah, it's a good
and straight blade.
I'm going to concentrate
on the handle.
It' starting to look
like a guard [inaudible]..
First up, I think I'm
going to weld a bolt on it
for a threaded pommel.
Well, that looks very
good, but too bad.
I put my handle together.
I want to make sure
to get a tight fit.
Don't want anything loose.
Ooh!
I wished I had more
time on the detail work,
but let's go in there and
test it and let's get her done
and get it over with.
I'm ready.
CORDALE: My name is
Cordale Whitfield.
I'm 20 years old, and I'm
from Telephone, Texas.
I love bladesmithing because
I just like fire and metal.
Now for the spicy bit.
As I'm going to quench, I
really hope I don't pull it
out and turn it into a banana.
Now is the grind marathon.
Today I definitely have
to finish the handle.
I know exactly what
I'm going to do.
I'm going to do a leather stack.
With a leather stack,
and I got to do
is stack it up,
glue it together,
and put the pommel on.
So, onto leather.
I just got to finish shaping
the handle, I got to sharpen it,
and then that's it.
For this part of the
program, we will now start
at the mystery inscription.
A medieval mystery sword
got a mysterious inscription
that nobody can figure out.
Pretty good.
I'm going to scratch off the
letters, and I'll etch that,
and then I'll just
etch the letters
and it will leave
my blade shiny.
I believe that's gonna work.
I like how it turned out.
Oh, yeah.
That's a pretty sharp blade.
Let's go chop up
some water bottles.
There you go.
He gone.
I'm definitely
proud of this sword.
I can't wait to see it
tested, and hopefully
come away with that 10 grand.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
The legendary Medieval
Sword of Mystery.
Well, the first mystery we're
going to solve right now
is are they lethal?
Cordale, you're up first.
You ready for this?
I suppose.
All right, let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Cordale, let's
talk about your Medieval Sword
of Mystery.
First up, your
handle construction.
Your handle is nice and smooth.
The one issue I have is
it has all this space.
Now, let's talk about your edge.
These boars are no joke.
They're very tough
to cut through,
but your edge made easy cuts
and thrust on this boar carcass.
And I finally figured out what
that word right there says--
"it will kill."
Thank you.
Larry, your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
Guys, I think we have
a parameter issue here
that we need to talk about.
Quick huddle?
Well, Larry, it seems that Doug
saw something with your blade
that he wants to discuss
further with the judges.
So gentlemen, while
they talk, I'm
going to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
All right, the guys are out.
What did you see?
Well, what I did not see on
Larry's sword is a disk pommel.
We asked him to replicate
an iconic legendary Medieval
Sword of Mystery.
That's not a style of a blade,
that's one particular blade.
When you look at that, it's
got one form, one look.
We put these parameters
down, because we
want everything to test evenly.
It's not the sword we asked for.
Yeah, this pommel
is not a vague idea.
You wanted this pommel for
counterbalance on the blade.
Also, you want that swell where
it is much larger than the
handle itself for retention.
But what we have on Larry's,
it actually tapers smaller
than the handle, so
there's a good chance
of swinging it and having
it fly out of your hand
and endanger people around you.
Well, you guys all
on the same page?
Yeah.
All right, we'll
call them back in.
All right, Larry, we
got a bit of an issue.
We asked you guys to recreate
the Medieval Sword of Mystery.
Now, part of that sword
is the disk-shaped pommel.
The judges have
talked it through,
and they've decided that
your pommel does not
fit within the definition
of a disk-shaped pommel,
so unfortunately, it
is a parameter failure.
Larry, one of the parameters
for the Sword of Mystery
was a disk pommel.
Two biggest reasons for
that, aside from the fact
it was part of the
original design,
is having that mass back
there to retain the sword
while it's being
swung, also, the weight
to counterbalance the blade.
Your pommel doesn't
have that, and we're
worried that swinging
that, it could
go flying across the room.
Well, Larry, you
fought hard through this,
but unfortunately, with the
parameter failure and the fact
that the judges can't test your
blade fairly against Cordale's,
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
Thank you for [inaudible]
gentleman, appreciate it.
- Thank you.
- Good fight.
LARRY: Yeah, I'm
disappointed with it.
I wanted to see it perform.
I was running up against
the clock, running close,
so I worked up to the last
minute getting it done,
and I forgot my disk pommel.
That's how it goes,
but I had a good time.
Well, Cordale, your
hard work paid off.
You are the newest
Forged in Fire champion,
and you just won yourself
a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
I'm pretty excited.
I hate to win it
this way, but I'm
excited to win it nonetheless.
You won, fair and square.
Well done.
- Good job, Cordale.
Good job.
I doubt I'll
make another sword,
but I was very happy with my
blade and I had a lot of fun.